and hi my name is that out Phillips of
Ireland and the question is quite a
broad one for them did you explain what
is background radiation and what
relevance is what happened exactly the
Big Bang okay it so you're asking what
is background radiation what astronomers
mean is radiation that comes to us
almost the same brightness from every
direction in the sky imagining that
we're outside the Earth's atmosphere and
outside the solar system to make a
measurement so this would be radiation
that comes from the entire cosmos and so
that's why we call it background we
can't recognize any individual source
otherwise we would say well that
radiation came from a galaxy or a planet
or a star so background radiation is
radiation that has no obvious individual
source must come from the cosmos as a
whole so there are several kinds of
background radiation that we study and
one is called the cosmic microwave
radiation and it's the primordial heat
from the Big Bang material it's really
quite bright it's about a micro watt per
square meter and so it's hard for us to
measure but it's really quite bright
there are other kinds that are gamma
rays or x-rays or other wave wavelengths
of infrared where we haven't yet
identified where all this radiation
comes from but we sort of imagine that
it comes from individual stars or
galaxies that we just haven't been able
to identify nevertheless it's an
interesting question
because down do you know if you found
everything in the universe you have to
be able to account for all of this
radiation that may or may not come from
something you know about so you're not
done with astronomy until you can
explain where all the background
radiation comes from that makes it
interesting even though it's sort of
hard to measure it so the cosmic
microwave background radiation is
different from all the others that we
know about because we think that it
comes from the Big Bang material itself
and it comes to us from all directions
because the universe is so immensely
large that every direction that we look
we're looking at a piece of the Big Bang
material when we look far enough back in
time so to us it looks like it's
completely uniform are almost completely
uniform so we can't detect a center or
an edge of the universe by looking at
this material it's very startling to
people that we cannot find
Center or edge but there seems to be no
center or edge there is on the other
hand the farthest you can look you
cannot see back in time any farther than
the age of the universe so you can't see
any farther than light will travel in
the age of the universe so there's an
observable edge but not a real edge as
far as we know